los vídeos les estaba contando muy
rápidamente porque el l no es un
criterio de congruencia válido es decir
que no es un criterio que nos permita
concluir que dos triángulos son
congruentes en este vídeo quiero
explorar esto un poco más a este
criterio también podemos llamarlo a l l
pero es más divertido llamarlo el l
porque entonces podemos llamar el
criterio ya o más animadamente el
criterio ya así con mucha energía bueno
vamos a hacer un dibujo de un triángulo
por acá supongamos que tenemos un
triángulo que se ve más o menos así que
se vea enorme está quedando muy flaco
voy a dibujarlo otra vez a ver suponemos
que el triángulo se ve más o menos así
ya ahí quedó un poco mejor lo
completamos por acá y supongamos que
encontramos otro triángulo en el cual
tenemos varias magnitudes en común para
empezar vamos a suponer que ambos
comparten el lado que estoy pintando con
rosa luego tienen un segundo lado
congruentes un segundo lado congruente
que está adyacente a este lado voy a
pintar que es este de acá este que estoy
pintando con azul pues estamos
suponiendo que es congruente a este lado
y ese segundo lado es adyacente a un
triángulo que también es un ángulo
con el otro triángulo entonces
supongamos que este ángulo de aquí
también lo tiene el otro triángulo este
ángulo es el ángulo opuesto al primer
lado que dibujamos entonces ahí tenemos
lo necesario para un criterio de léela o
bueno si quieres reírte un poquito
recuerda que también podemos llamar el
criterio ya pero bueno como le hacemos
para concluir que el 'enano' es un
criterio de congruencia lo que
necesitamos ver es que este criterio
causa ambigüedad para verificar esto
vamos a hacer un dibujo adicional
supongamos que tomamos un dibujo por acá
que el ángulo lo tiene igual ahora
además de esto vamos a poner en azul uno
de los lados adyacentes al ángulo esto
lo hacemos para indicar que es
congruente al del primer triángulo ahora
vamos a dibujar aquí abajo el lado
restante en verde y vamos a extenderlo a
la derecha no sabemos cuánto miden pero
como sabemos el ángulo sabemos en qué
dirección va entonces voy a pasar este
lado del triángulo derecho por acá lo
voy a poner punteado porque no sabemos
qué tan largo es pero sabemos que va en
esa dirección ahora que más tenemos que
copiar tenemos que copiar el lado rosa
este tercer lado lo tenemos que copiar
o triángulo y para esto podemos pivotear
lo en este vértice superior puede hacer
cualquier ángulo porque el ángulo no lo
tenemos determinado pero éste tiene que
bajar tiene que bajar hasta alcanzar la
base entonces puede ser que baje así y
entonces si nos quedan dos triángulos
que son congruentes pero entonces
aquí vemos que surge una ambigüedad pues
hay otra forma de completar el triángulo
del lado izquierdo también se puede
bajar la longitud que queremos
obteniendo dos formas de completar el
triángulo y las dos nos dan triángulos
diferentes por aquí o por allá tenemos
dos triángulos diferentes que cumplen el
criterio y entonces qué pasa pasa que
tenemos cierta ambigüedad hay dos formas
de bajar el lado y entonces el criterio
no nos da suficiente información para
determinar que los triángulos son
definitivamente congruentes hay algunos
casos especiales si tomamos en cuenta
algunos ángulos analicemos la situación
en el ejemplo que acabamos de ver este
ángulo aquí fue agudo y acá también es
agudo porque es el mismo entonces cuando
tenemos un ángulo agudo los otros
ángulos los otros ángulos todavía
podrían ser tal vez obtuso
entonces bueno recordemos que agudo es
menos de 90 grados que obtuso es más de
90 grados entonces una opción es que
tengamos otros dos ángulos agudos voy a
marcar este de por acá a todos agudos
agudos agudos pero hay una opción cuando
baja aquí hacia la izquierda que se hace
un ángulo obtuso aquí en la base
entonces aquí nos quedaría un ángulo
obtuso cómo podemos evitar eso pues si
el ángulo inicial fuera obtuso no podría
aparecer un segundo ángulo obtuso porque
no puede haber dos ángulos de más de 90
grados entonces por eso ahí existe la
posibilidad en la cual cuando tenemos a
ver voy a hacer otro dibujo para
explicar mi idea vamos a pintar un
segundo triángulo que se vea así
imaginemos que por alguna razón del
destino sabemos que este ángulo que
estoy marcando es obtuso lo que vamos a
ver es que si este ángulo obtuso es el
ángulo a en el criterio l l a entonces
si se puede utilizar el l como criterio
de congruencia veamos por qué pasa esto
lo primero es copiar el ángulo vamos a
poner que el lado adyacente a este
ángulo sea congruente y que el adyacente
a ese otro también sea congruente voy a
hacer un triángulo para qué
vamos que en este caso el criterio no
causa en vigo edad entonces déjenme
hacer un dibujo un segundo dibujo para
ver que el triángulo queda determinado
ponemos ahí el ángulo y recordemos que
el ángulo de la base no sabemos cuánto
mide pero sabemos su dirección entonces
lo ponemos punteado pero lo que sí
sabemos lo que sí sabemos es que el lado
de aquí de la izquierda el lado que es
adyacente al ángulo si mide lo mismo lo
voy a pintar con rosa por aquí y además
sabemos que un tercer lado lo voy a
hacer con color naranja sabemos que el
tercer lado que estoy marcando aquí con
naranja también mide lo mismo ahora no
sabemos nada del ángulo de aquí arriba y
entonces el lado puede hacer pivot en
este vértice puede rotar pero sólo hay
una forma en la cual el lado naranja
puede bajar a la base la única forma es
esta de aquí es decir bajarlo hacia la
derecha y esto fue porque el ángulo
obtuso no restricción más las
condiciones y entonces hubo una única
forma de bajar el lado con esto ya
tenemos que los dos triángulos si se
vuelven congruentes pero cuidado no
quiero que pienses que siempre que le
lea es un criterio de congruencia
usamos de manera muy importante que el
ángulo a era obtuso solo quería
contarles este caso especial en el cual
el ángulo obtuso nos quita un poco de
ambigüedad finalmente bueno aquí arriba
tenemos un ángulo agudo y abajo tenemos
el caso con el ángulo obtuso pero hay un
caso intermedio verdad que es el ángulo
recto entonces qué pasa cuando a es un
ángulo recto el ángulo a en él ya vamos
a hacer un dibujo por acá ponemos el
ángulo recto imagínense que sabemos la
base que no sabemos cuánto mide pero que
va por ahí y que tenemos fijo un lado
vamos a suponer que tenemos fijo este
lado azul y además sabemos la longitud
del tercer lado si lo pensamos un
poquito este este tercer lado va a ser
opuesto al ángulo recto y por tanto es
la hipotenusa entonces la única forma en
la cual podemos bajar la hipotenusa con
una medida determinada es bajarla hacia
el lado derecho de esta forma entonces
si nos damos cuenta las observaciones de
este tercer caso nos dan un nuevo
criterio de congruencia a éste lo
podemos llamar el criterio rl h
abreviando recto lado hipotenusa si nos
da
cuenta esto es lo mismo que poner el l a
pero para cuando el ángulo es recto en
derecho aquí estoy golpeando un poco el
orden que hemos estado usando en
realidad estas siglas corresponderían al
criterio a l l porque el ángulo va
primero no importa mucho porque ya
habíamos dicho que el l l era en un
mismo criterio pero bueno si lo pensamos
un poquito usando un poco de sentido
común podíamos pensar que esta
información se podía obtener a partir
del teorema de pitágoras no hemos
hablado mucho de eso pero si ya lo sabes
puedes pensarlo así si tienes dos lados
y un ángulo recto puedes encontrar el
tercer lado utilizando el teorema de
pitágoras y entonces podemos usar el
criterio lll este es otro caso especial
pero lo más importante es recordar que
el l
no es un criterio suficiente